[Música]
a todos los presentes
gracias a dios por concederme estar con
ustedes el conceder me salud y vida
y gracias a esta casa de estudios de
bellas artes con 101 años de establecida
aquí
y hace tres que viene trabajando entre
la comunidad
muchas gracias por estar acá
perdón perdón es que esto señora elsa
mil disculpas lo que pasa es que somos
tan magnéticos de que todo salga bien
que yo le voy a robar esto usted solo se
va a quedar con eso y en un abrazo
además
y cosas del modernismo
dice de las reflexiones mi barrio y su
comunidad
mi barrio barrios altos
tengo ese orgullo de decir mi barrio
barrios altos encierra las cinco patas
principales de nuestra historia y están
allí presentes para poderlas mirar tocar
recordar estudiar y seguir aprendiendo
cada día más de ello
de contemplar nuestra riqueza
patrimonial que muy pocos países tienen
lo que nosotros tenemos
barrios altos cuna de la nobleza y de la
identidad peruana sobre todo
y aquí
que les puedo decir a lo largo de todos
estos años de trabajo comunitario no me
jacto de ser la única persona que lo
hace si no hago un algo chiquitito pero
voy haciéndolo día tras día y luego con
la esperanza de que algún día
barrios altos vuelva a recuperar su
prestancia y relevancia que tuvo en los
años pasados
hay muchas personas que nos miran mal
que piensan que todos son delincuentes
no es así
no es así ningún niño nace malo todos
los niños son buenos son ángeles de la
tierra
y por ellos es mi emoción
al perú a barrios altos y a los niños
dice cómo fueron mis inicios trabajando
por barrios altos efectivamente tengo 40
años empecé en los años 80 cuando cuando
está participada en cruz roja
y
luego un lugar dentro de la disciplina
sinceridad y más que nada con amor
porque la disciplina porque para hacer
algo siempre hay que tener un orden no
se puede hacer así tomar las cosas
siempre hay que conversar dialogar
saber y conocer
no es solamente saber yo sé que todos
los profesionales saben mucho pero no
todos conocen la problemática de barrios
altos o de monserrate o del ritmo que
son las partes integrantes del centro
histórico y que hoy en día
están precisamente dentro de ese legado
que se acaba de firmar el día jueves que
es el plan maestro de niva que en
realidad me desconcierta un poco son los
años que duran decíamos que hasta el
2030 ayer el periódico 2035 y hoy día
veo que es el 2040 bueno ya no lo veré
pero lo verán ustedes
está este trabajo continuo diario que se
viene haciendo conversando con una y
otra persona las necesidades que se
pueden
ayudar que pueden ayudar a hacerlo y que
hay muchos jóvenes que han plasmado sus
tesis de historia de ciencias sociales
de comunicación psicología
aquí con los temas de barrios altos
a ellos les agradezco
son seres anónimos para mí creo que me
devuelven adiós como les vuelve decir lo
que yo les da
hay muchas personas que ya se han hecho
profesionales
y con ellos
ahí estos libros
y se pagó
y luego logré creo
si me ayudan por favor
este
tenemos por ejemplo en los papeles
momentos lo que se viene haciendo con la
universidad nacional mayor de san marcos
lo de cama de américa
cuántos años en la universidad acá en
lima en el corazón del imán porque no
leemos solamente barrio santo sino todo
lima
cuántos años metidos en las aulas
trabajando en los laboratorios en sus
investigaciones y todos
pero yo ahora algo hacen por ejemplo las
universidades de las facultades de
medicina san fernando a cargo del doctor
gustavo franco durante dos años
consecutivos viene trabajando todo lo
que la temática es de salud en los
solares quintás y callejones de nuestra
comunidad tiene el área de también la
facultad de farmacia y bioquímica que
está entre wanda y puno
también periódicamente con campañas de
análisis gratuitos en números de 100 100
personas
sean primero pasadas derivadas a sus
analizar respectivos
tenemos también dentro de la facultad de
ciencias sociales estela
y run que es un grupo de profesionales
que vienen trabajando a cargo de la
historiadora milagros romero con un
grupo de muchos profesionales de
distintas profesiones y ellos están
vienen trabajando ahorita en siguen la
recuperación de cinco patios culturales
en este eje de antes para ahora y guanta
y ha sido bastante difícil para entrar a
cada uno de ellos pero es un hermoso
proyecto con toda la voluntad tanto de
amor con todo cariño lo hacen estos
chicos y yo les agradezco de todo
corazón de donde esté siempre los
mencionó
tenemos aquí donde estamos bellas artes
como les decía el año pasado cumplieron
100 años pero ya hacía dos años que
veníamos trabajando con la
con la subdirección de proyección social
a cargo del licenciado julio huamán y de
la docente el saber en suela viajarán a
una gran mujer que pone mucho más del
tiempo que es su trabajo aquí en la
escuela por supuesto cómo ven y el señor
director pero
se han abocado a la comunidad hacen
enseñanza talleres concursos veníamos
trabajando en los primeros años del
primer año en las clases italia
después ya estuvimos en la comisaría se
sacó un concurso la tarjeta que he
ganado el trabajo ganador se convirtió
en una tarjeta de saludo navideño y
ellos mismos los plasmaron en tarjeta y
se saludo a todas las instituciones
públicas fue el saludo de navidad una
cosa muy bonita porque fue el
pensamiento de la niña que había ganado
dos años consecutivos
se ha entrelazado bellas artes con el
poder judicial
el poder judicial en estos momentos
tiene una comisión de acceso a la
justicia en tu comunidad
esta comisión la preside la fuerza
suprema doctora yanet guilarte quien
está comprometida de lleno con las 100
reglas de brasilia se ha firmado en un
convenio entre varios países extranjeros
europeos y americanos y se viene
trabajando en este momento se encuentra
ella en cayey y trabajando con las 34
cortes judiciales que tiene el país pero
que han hecho ellos no solamente vean
los expedientes de justicia estaba preso
este sable no es una mujer
que cuando muy joven en la universidad
ya para salir de ella vino al barrio se
trajo un grupo de profesionales y en su
caminar con abogada encontró que el
principal problema en barrios altos eran
las partes faltarán partidos los niños
no tenían partidas de nacimiento no
estaban reconocidos en ese tiempo pasaba
unos ocho días y el niño que no era
firmado se quedaba sin poder tener su
partida es ese estudio es ese trajinar
de día a día sirvió para juntar todos
los documentos y presentarlos al
congreso en lo que se consiguió la
inscripción de partidas extemporáneas
que nos ha servido a muchos
muchísimo porque de ahí ya podían
estudiar podían tener su platita para
sus alimentos porque a veces los
caballeros se olvidan de los niños y no
le pasan la manutención entonces todo
eso ella lo capto les sirvió ese
aprendizaje de caminar calle bomba
porque ayudan dormido de la mano
y hoy en día en agradecimiento viene a
barrios altos ha traído muchas navidades
hace la quería [ __ ] ya tres años
consecutivos acá
ha formado un grupo de orientadoras a
nivel de lima metropolitana 350 mujeres
50 son de barrios altos
eso
todo totalmente gratuito señores quién
soy yo un ama de casa abuela pobre
pero con la bendición de dios muy buenas
amistades que me sirven y todas
desinteresadamente no porque seamos los
más pobres y los más menesterosos niños
o no sino que él se siente en ellos con
ese amor con ese cariño de trabajar
por la comunidad y que mejor que hacerlo
aquí de lo que fue
la lima la línea virreinal esa lima rica
de antaño en belleza en tesoros en
patrimonio en historia en todo y si no
díganme por qué la beneficiencia tiene
tantísimas propiedades
porque lo mejor del inah estuvo aquí en
barrios altos
que muchas propiedades de esas son
propias y otras son solamente
administrados que de esta administración
pero ella dice son nuestras
aquí grandes familias han donado la
familia de osma la corrió en me gusta
alicia la atrevida de la calle muchas
familias han donado sus propiedades
para ponerlas en manos de ellos pero por
la administración sin embargo muchos han
aparecido vendidas eso debo decirlo con
claridad
quien le puedo decir más adelante es qué
yo espero que este té que también reúne
profesionales
pueda hacer algo por nuestros niños
yo sé que la buena voluntad con el
cariño se puede hacer muchas cosas
me normal hasta ahorita lo que he hecho
con mucho amor
con una voluntad propia porque nadie me
obliga
y con una disciplina dentro de esa
disciplina
ponemos el orden
ponemos el [ __ ] y la transparencia
como la transparencia dentro de los
valores
y principios que debe regir nuestra
sociedad
gracias al señor que me da estas fuerzas
que todavía mientras que él me tenga con
salud y con vida seguiré pidiendo por
mis niños ya los ancianos
sí es verdad que tenemos muchos derechos
pero los niños son el presente y son el
futuro de nuestro país en el sentido de
que puedan ser ellos grandes
profesionales porque si queremos tener
una patria libre una patria
independiente y progresiva tenemos que
fundar la escuela y en la escuela que
están las enseñanzas aparte de las
enseñanzas del hogar que son con
formación muchas gracias
amigos buenas tardes
[Aplausos]
t
[Música]